new cases of the coronavirus are ticking
up in some parts of the u.s with the
omicron sub-variant ba2 now the dominant
strain now the numbers are still far
below the surge we saw earlier this year
that's some good news but for more on
all of it we're going to bring in dr
ashish jaw he is the biden
administration's new coronavirus
response coordinator and he joins us now
not from brown university but from the
white house good morning dr jah
good morning tony thanks for having me
here
so let's start uh doctor with the
increase in cases we're seeing in some
parts of the country you've said in the
past very reasonably that if we see a
change in the case count we might need
to go back to masking mandates uh do you
see that trending in that direction now
yeah so good news tony is that infection
numbers are still very low compared to
historical averages right and
hospitalizations the metric we care
about most
are at their lowest level in the entire
pandemic so i do believe we're going to
see cases go up and down obviously if it
gets substantially worse we're going to
want to look at
issues like masking but at this moment
these numbers are still quite low and i
think we need to continue focusing on
protecting people with vaccines and
treatments
and not i don't think we need to make
any other substantial changes at this
point that's great that's terrific news
a little trickier news is congress
congress has yet to vote on funding
for
the continued fight against the
coronavirus if that vote is delayed
deeper into the spring how might that
affect your efforts and our national
efforts to fight the virus
yeah you know one of the things that
we've been able to accomplish in the
last year and a half is we have now
vaccinated more than 200 million
americans
we have treatments that are much more
widely available how did we get there
well that was the effort of the bite
administration but it's also support of
congress through resources and when we
look into the summer and fall and when
we all want to make sure there are
plenty of vaccines available for people
that we continue to have treatments
available for the american people none
of that is going to be possible without
additional funding from congress and
that's why i remain very confident that
congress is going to step up and do its
part tony but it's really pretty
essential that they do that
the current senate bill has 10 billion
in funding to fight the virus is that
enough
yeah it's a down payment i think the
administration initially
asked for 80 they cut it down to 22 and
a half so the question is what do we
need this money for we need it for
vaccines we need to make sure that we
have plenty of testing available
we need to make sure that we have plenty
of treatments available
that's all going to be essential and
we're going to need the resources to
make sure that we have that for the
american people
if you had the money would boosters
which the messaging on boosters has been
a little bit confusing would the
recommendation from a medical public
health perspective be boosters for
everyone
now right now um here's what we know is
we know if you've only had two shots and
you're an adult you need to get that
third shot that's all adults should be
getting that that's very clear the
question now has come up in the last
couple of weeks what about that second
booster
very good evidence from israel that
people over 60 should get a booster i
think that part's pretty clear 50 to 59
if you have risk factors reasonable
under 50 we just don't have any data we
always want to be guided on by data on
these things and right now i'd say under
50 second booster
no evidence yet first booster every
adult needs one
all right dr ja uh congratulations on
the new role glad to hear the country is
still in a pretty good place and we'll
keep our eyes on congress for you
appreciate it thank you thank you so
much tony